mesdames messieurs bon dimanche les
attentes des provinces et des
territoires étaient énormes l'offre de
tawa était reçu avec déception et
résignation le gouvernement fédéral
propose d'injecter 48 milliards de
dollars sur 10 ans en nouveau
financement pour la santé non plus de la
moitié sera dirigé vers des ententes
bilatérales juste un Trudeau parle d'un
investissement significatif à la hauteur
des moyens du gouvernement fédéral mais
estime surtout que l'argent à lui seul
n'est pas l'unique solution au problème
du système de santé
on a la mode dans nos quand on parle
d'investissement en santé de toujours
parler de combien d'argent on est en
train d'investir un milliard ici 100
millions là
mais ce qui est important pour les
citoyens pour les familles pour les
aînés
c'est si oui ou non ils vont avoir accès
à un médecin de famille puis ça c'est
pas juste une question de dollars
de la santé bonjour bonjour monsieur
Thibault bonjour à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent vous avez déposé devant les
provinces et territoires cette semaine
vous et Monsieur Trudeau l'offre de
financement du gouvernement fédéral bien
en dessous de ce que demandait les
provinces pourquoi cette marge pourquoi
vous êtes pas allé les rejoindre un peu
plus loin effectivement 48 milliards de
financements nouveaux annoncé cette
semaine sur un total de 200 milliards
pour les 10 prochaines années par
rapport au niveau actuel donc 200
milliards de plus mais 48 ou 49
milliards nouvellement annoncé la
semaine dernière est-ce que les demandes
des provinces étaient des les provinces
c'est mais c'est normal monsieur
Thibault aussi Premier ministre si je
l'étais ce serait notre job d'A demandé
toujours plus mais ce qui est important
de reconnaître c'est que un cet argent a
du sens seulement s'il se traduit en
résultat pour les patients et pour les
travailleurs et les résultats qu'on a
convenu d'améliorer au cours des
prochaines années avec les ministres à
sa santé depuis un an qu'on travaille
ensemble c'est un meilleur accès à des
équipes de médecine familiales réduire
les retards en chirurgie en investissant
davantage dans les travailleurs en les
retenant entre autres investir en santé
mentale pour les jeunes et avoir un
système de soins de santé qui est plus
moderne qui sauve davantage de vie qui
livre des meilleures qualités de soins
parce qu'on n'a pas besoin se promener
avec des sacs et des bouts de papier
pour aller consulter un médecin ou aller
rencontrer une formation vous vous misez
beaucoup sur ça la modernité du système
les données l'accès aux données pourquoi
à quel point ça peut faire une
différence pour la personne qui nous
regarde à la maison là ce matin il y a
pas de médecins de famille qui a pas
accès la chirurgie dont il ou elle a
besoin à quel point l'idée d'échanger
des données ça fait une différence parce
que les données ça sauve des vies si
vous allez tomber inconscient le
l'ambulancier vous rencontre aucune
espèce d'idée des médicaments que vous
prenez des allergies que vous avez il
peut pas accéder au test auquel que vous
avez eu dans les dernières semaines même
chose pour l'urgenteologue à l'urgence
où vous allez il peut pas il connaît pas
votre dossier médical est obligé de
refaire faire faire des tests dans ce
temps-là votre santé se détériore c'est
beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de temps qui
sont perdus des la qualité de soins qui
est mise en jeu on estime à plusieurs
milliards de dollars juste en coût
financier sans pour l'enfant parler des
coûts humains la perte d'efficacité qui
est générée par un système de santé de
donner en santé qui était inférieure à
la norme qu'on trouve dans d'autres pays
il y a deux éléments que vous soulevez
là-dedans il y a les dossiers médicaux
des Canadiens puis elle échange de
donner pour mesurer les performances des
systèmes de santé vous imposez pas de
conditions là-dessus vous dites on s'est
entendu pour des données mais il y a pas
de bâton pour imposer aux provinces de
vous les donner où il y a pas de bâtons
pour dire aux Provin j'ai vu les données
puis ça fonctionne pas je vais tenter
d'enlever du financement comment vous
allez rentrer efficace mais il y a une
chose qu'on a fait puis il y a deux
choses qu'on va faire à ce sujet la
première c'est que depuis un an les
ministres la santé des provinces et
moi-même on travaille très bien et avec
pas mal de bons résultats pour avoir
identifié des priorités communes la
deuxième chose c'est que il va y avoir
des plans d'action qui vont être écrits
par les provinces et les territoires
c'est à eux que reviennent revient la
responsabilité de gérer les soins de
santé c'est eux qui vont écrire des
plans d'action qui vont les communiquer
au canadiens des plan d'actions qui vont
être tournés vers les priorités qu'on
vient d'identifier la troisième chose
c'est qu'il va y avoir effectivement des
indicateurs de rendement de performance
et de progrès au cours des prochaines
années que les gens vont pouvoir suivre
par exemple au Québec on sait qu'on est
un petit peu en retard par rapport à
d'autres provinces en matière d'accès à
des équipes de médecine familiales
est-ce qu'on peut améliorer ça pour
arriver à un homme plus canadienne des
progrès peuvent être observés au cours
des prochaines années entre autres avec
les investissements du gouvernement
canadien donc vous vous pensez que la
pression les gens du public les
Canadiens qui vont voir les données la
pression que ces gens-là pour imposer
sur les gouvernements provinciaux et
suffisant pour les faire aller dans la
direction sur laquelle vous vous êtes
ententes c'est ça téléphone question de
respect et de transparence le respect
dans le sens que c'est pas au
gouvernement canadien fait confiance
dans le fond un peu oui parce que je les
connais très bien puis je sais qu'on a
exactement les mêmes objectifs on sert
les mêmes personnes avec les mêmes
dollars qui viennent les mêmes poches
les mêmes contribuables donc on était
lignée on est là pour les mêmes les
mêmes raisons et au cours des prochaines
années ben ils vont bénéficier d'un
appui supplémentaire pour faire
exactement ce qu'ils aimeraient faire au
cours des prochaines
alors qu'on a tellement l'impression que
ça a pas marché dans le passé où ça a
été difficile d'imposer cette espèce de
de rythme commun de out à l'autre du
pays
ça va aller mieux mais deux on se parle
très sérieusement Daniel les prochaines
années difficile quand même en matière
de soins de santé parce que le
vieillissement par exemple va continuer
mettre des pressions énormes sur les
travailleurs les travailleurs
vieillissent les gens vieillissent avec
des corps plus complexes on a aussi le
fait que les technologies deviennent de
plus en plus coûteuses même chose pour
les médicaments les maladies chroniques
et infectieuses sont de plus en plus
répandues donc ce n'est pas en quelques
semaines ou même en quelques mois que on
va voir un changement rapide dans la
qualité la sécurité des soins pour les
centres pour les patients vous avez dit
cette semaine l'argent ne règlera pas
tout qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui devrait
être qu'est-ce qui devrait servir
d'exemple comme système de santé aux
provinces canadiennes sur quoi vous vous
basez pour dire il y a des modifications
à faire dans le système vous devriez
faire comme eux là-bas
parce que l'argent s'il n'est pas
traduit en résultat ça change rien là si
l'argent du gouvernement canadien n'est
pas utilisé pour améliorer les résultats
pour les patients et pour les
travailleurs ça c'est un non sens la
deuxième chose c'est qu'il y a des
endroits dans notre système de santé où
il est plus important d'investir à la
fois parce que ce sont des endroits qui
sont maintenant plus fragiles santé
familiales l'équipe de médecine
familiale au Québec en particulier et
parce que si on investit dans ça un plus
grand accès à des soins centrales
primaires mais on réduit les coûts qu'il
y a à hospitalisé les gens lorsque leur
santé c'est trop dégradé d'ailleurs ça
coûte beaucoup plus cher de traiter
quelqu'un à l'urgence que de le traiter
par une équipe de médecine familiale les
coûts à l'hôpital c'est c'est hors de
proportions par rapport à des coûts
beaucoup moins et des résultats beaucoup
mieux qu'on aurait avoir un meilleur
accès au Québec en particulier à des
équipes de médecine familiales la mesure
du succès pour vous quelle est-elle mais
c'est un pays où on continue à prendre
soin de tout le monde on a un système de
santé qui est public puis tous les
experts s'entendent pour dire c'est un
système de santé qui est qui est le
potentiel d'être moins coûteux de donner
des meilleurs résultats en termes de
santé individuel et de santé publique et
d'être plus équitable contrairement à
d'autres systèmes qui coûtent plus cher
qui sont moins équitables et moins
efficaces qu'est-ce qui serait vous la
réalisation la plus importante dans tout
ce qui a été discuté cette semaine
donner espoir au travailleur au médecin
aux infirmières aux infirmières
praticiennes ou préposés aux
bénéficiaires aux pharmaciens et aux
pharmaciens qui prennent un rôle de plus
en plus important dans notre
dans notre communauté et notre système
de soins de santé c'est de leur donner
espoir puis leur dire qu'on va être là
pour prendre soin d'eux pour que eux
puissent prendre soin de nous j'arrive
du Clos merci beaucoup merci